my name is Brian Daugherty on the senior
editor recent magazine and the author of
the new book Ron Paul's revolution the
man and the movement he inspired
the most people who gather under the
banner of the modern tea party don't
know it Ron Paul and the Ron Paul
campaign back in the year 2007 invented
the notion of the modern Tea Party they
held their historical record making
money bomb on that day December
sixteenth and 2007 gathering the largest
amount of money that any presidential
campaign has ever gathered in one day
and held Tea Party events near various
bodies of water across the country you
had ron paul himself thrown a barrel
marked iraq war into the water in his
home district of texas you had Rand Paul
his son who later became Senator Rand
Paul from Kentucky leading a tea party
event in 2007 in the city of Boston
itself as jon stewart actually said
later when defending ron paul against
his brethren in the media who liked to
ignore him when it comes to the Tea
Party grassroots Ron Paul is the man who
planted those seeds he is the real deal
we're asked a lot of the modern tea
partiers are really just moral
majoritarian tanned tri-cornered hats
Ron Paul invented the notion of a
populists activist modern movement that
trans partisan and isn't only anti taxes
which you know everyone short of the New
Republic is but it's actually anti
spending and actually wants to shrink
government the problem is Ron Paul
himself will tell a modern Tea Partiers
is that they've ignored the foreign
policy part of the equation that if you
want to shrink government you need to
shrink the part of government that is
bankrupting us overseas with these
expensive and ruinous foreign
interventions as well one of Ron Paul's
greatest political successes has been
popularizing popular discontent against
the Federal Reserve these monetary
policy issues have been Ron Paul's pet
concern since he first entered Congress
in the 1970s his background in Austrian
economics has led him to believe that
having this government entity the
Federal Reserve and giving it unlimited
power to create currency willy-nilly is
going to create booms and busts and he
saw as early as 2001 2002 that the
Federal Reserve was creating a housing
bubble that was going to pop in ways
that were going to be very
dangerous to the American economy Ron
Paul fans love sending you to youtube
videos from early in the twenty-first
century where Ron Paul is predicting the
housing bubble and the ruinous effects
it was going to have on the economy this
opposition to the Federal Reserve used
to be an extremely eccentric position on
the American political landscape this
year in Republican candidate debates you
had Newt Gingrich sounding almost more
anti fed than Ron Paul himself you had
Rick Perry talking about a holding Fed
Chairman Ben Bernanke up for treason Ron
Paul finally succeeded in getting his
audit the Fed bill which he's been
introducing for decades through the
House of Representatives he got every
single Republican to support it and
enough Democrats to support it to
actually get it in a bill that came out
of the house it did not succeed in
passing but the notion that the Federal
Reserve's power to inflate is dangerous
to the American economy is now widely
understood not only by economist but by
laypeople as well and I think this has
been one of Ron Paul's greatest
political successes
you